パンッ（手を叩く音）
（音楽🎶）
はっはっはっはっはっはっはっはっはっはっはっはっはっはっはっはぁー
うぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁーーーーーーーーーーーーーー
はいっ。というわけで宝物の中身は、トートバックでした。
うぁぁぁぁぁぁーーーーーーーーーーー
はいっ、というわけで今回はですね、クラロワとのコラボ動画で、こちらの５人で激闘を再現してみました。
でぇ、このトートバックなんですけれども、
大人気スマホゲーム、クッラシュモバイルの大型アップデートを記念して、
特別に作られたオリジナルグッズでございます。
そして見てください、このトートバック、
表にはベビードラゴンが印刷されておりまして、
そして、裏には、はじめしゃちょーが　こちらにプリントされておりまぁーーす！！
うぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁーーーーーーーーーーー
そしてこのトートバック、皆さん、ほしいですか？
このトートバック、ほしい皆さんの中から抽選で１００名様に
なんと、
プレゼントします！！！
うわぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁーーーー
クラシュロワイヤルは、世界中の人とさくさく遊べるアクションゲーム
キャラもめっちゃ強くて、かわいいぜ！！
いえぇぇぇぇぇぇぇい！！！
そしてなんと１２月には、
賞金、約４４００万を懸けた世界大会が、
ロンドンで、
開催されます！
うぁぁぁぁぁぁぁー！
そして１０月に大型アップデートされて、新しいモードも増えて、遊びやすくなりました。
オリジナルグッズのプレゼントに関しては
プレゼントの応募方法は
アプリは動画の概要欄からできますので
是非皆さんダウンロードして遊んでみてください。
それでは皆さんの応募、
お待ちしております。
やぁぁぁぁぁぁーーーー